The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LORNA GIBSON: So
last time we were
talking about trabecular bone
and that it's this porous kind
of foam-like type of bone.
And we talked a little
bit about the modeling.
And I think I got
as far as starting
to talk about osteoporosis.
And I wanted to talk today about
how we can model osteoporosis
using those voronoi
honeycombs that we
talked about a while
ago when we were
talking about the structure.
So Bruno has a project on
trabecular bone for the class.
And he needed bone samples.
And so we talked about
different kind of bone samples
we could get.
And the thing is if you
get human bone-- well,
there's all sorts of
issues about just handling
human bone and permissions,
and it's complicated.
So that was too complicated.
We've used bovine bone before.
You just go to
the slaughterhouse
and get bovine bone.
But one of the things
with trabecular bone
is because it grows in response
to loads, the geometry of it
can be different,
sort of architecture
can vary from one spot
in the bone to another.
And I have a colleague
who started doing tests
on whale bones,
just because it's
a way of getting
nice, uniform bone.
So I was on a Ph.D. Committee a
few years ago for a student who
was in the Woods Hole program.
She was at MIT, but was
doing Woods Hole thing.
And I don't know if you've heard
of the Atlantic right whales,
the North Atlantic right whales.
They're endangered.
There's about 500 of
them left in the world.
And they migrate between like
typically the Bay of Fundy
and off the Florida coast.
So they go up and
down the coast.
And they sometimes
get hit by ships.
And then bones break
and that kills them.
And her study was on ship
impacts on right whales.
And so I got to know
people at Woods Hole who
worked on whales.
So Bruno, I called up
my friend at Woods Hole.
And the Woods Hole guy
didn't have any bones.
But he put me in
touch with somebody
at the Mass Fish and
Wildlife Department.
And he had a couple
of whale vertebrae
that he was willing to give up.
So I got one of them for you.
So here it is.
So I went out to the Mass
Fish and Wildlife yesterday.
And they produced
this bone for me.
I could either pass it around.
It's not too heavy.
Or you could come up
and look afterwards.
Shall I pass it around?
Or do you want
came up afterwards?
Maybe come up-- pass it?
OK.
So one of the things
is our like vertebrae,
there's these things
that stick up like this.
There's one that's
missing off of this bone.
There should have been
one down here too.
But this is sort
of what's called
the body of the vertebrae.
And in human vertebrae
it's about that big.
But it's the same kind
of general structure.
There's these kind of
bony plates that come off.
And the body is almost
all trabecular bone.
So you can see on this side,
this is a growth plate here.
But on this side,
there normally would
have been a thin shell
of the cortical bone.
And when I pass it around, if
you look up at this point here,
you can see there's just
a little bit of that left.
But it's kind of
gotten worn out.
And the rest of
this, if you look,
you can see it's
the trabecular bone.
And you can see
it's pretty uniform,
which is why I thought this
might be good for your tests.
So I thought you should get
in touch with Mike Tarkanian.
And I talked to him a
little bit about cutting it
with a water jet cutter.
So I think we could use
the water jet cutter.
And I think I emailed you.
If you could cut it
in half, I'd like
to have some pictures
of it cut in half.
And he's got a diamond
corer, cylindrical corer.
So you could make little
cylindrical specimens.
And I know if you want to do
compression tests or beams.
AUDIENCE: Well, I was planning
to do compression tests.
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah,
so you could probably
use some kind of a bands or
something to cut them up.
So, and this is where the
spinal column goes through
in the whale.
So there you have it.
Anybody want to ask me
anything about the whale bone?
OK, so let me pass that around.
And I guess I have to tell
you a couple of other stories.
So while I was there, they
have a brand new building.
And it's all got solar
panels and geothermal heat.
And it's all very groovy.
And the guy who I was
talking to about the bone,
he wanted to give me a
little tour of the building.
And he said, oh, you've
got to see your freezer.
OK, so the freezer.
So he opens the freezer door.
The freezer's like a room.
And there's like a bear.
I'm serious, like a
bear on the floor,
like a dead bear on the
floor of the freezer.
And he said it was like a
two-year-old bear that had,
I guess, just come out of
hibernation a couple weeks ago.
I think it had gotten hit
by a car or something.
And somebody must
have called them up.
And they have it.
So they had this bear.
They had like several deer.
They had a coyote.
They had like boxes full
of all kinds of animals.
So anyway it was kind
interesting to see
all these animals there.
And you know what he
said about the deer?
He said, normally deer in
Massachusetts don't starve.
Like if you live in the
suburbs, you actually
have a problem with deer
eating your vegetable garden
because there's deer
all over the place.
But he said, this winter, you
know how much snow we've had
and how cold it's been?
He said, deer have been
starving this winter.
And I think a couple
of the deer they'd had
had actually starved to death.
And people had called up.
And they had come and kind
of collected the carcasses.
So anyway that was
my little trip out
to Mass Fish and
Wildlife yesterday.
OK, so let's go back to
talking about the bone.
And I think last time we kind
of left off more or less here.
So this was a slide of what
osteoporosis looks like.
And you can see the bone
loss is a combination
of thinning of the struts
and resorption of the struts.
And we wanted to
try to model this,
sort of an engineering sense.
And the way we did that is we
used our voronoi honeycombs.
So the bone has an
irregular structure.
And we wanted to look and see
if we could model something that
had an irregular structure.
So we used the
voronoi honeycomb.
And if you remember
when we talked
about the structure
of cellular materials
earlier on in the
course, we said
that these are generated by
putting down random seed points
and then drawing the
perpendicular bisectors.
And if you have a constraint
that the seed points can't
be closer than some
exclusion distance,
then you get structure
where you have
cells that are not all exactly
the same size, but roughly
the same size.
So that's what we did here.
We got this structure here.
And I had a graduate
student, Matt Silva,
who did a lot of these studies.
And then he used
this and analyzed it
using finite element analysis.
So the first thing he did was
he calculated the elastic moduli
of the structure.
So he applied loads.
We calculated deformations.
Figured out elastic moduli.
And so this plot here
shows a comparison
between the analytical
equations that we derived
at the first part of
the course and what
he calculated for these
voronoi honeycombs
for the final element analysis.
So here's Young's modulus
down here, for example.
In the closed form,
the line, that's
just the analytical
equation we had originally.
And the little dashed line
is his finite element.
Here's the Shear
modulus down here.
And here's the
possum's ratio up here.
So you can see, there's
a pretty good agreement
between these two things here.
So let me write some
of this on the board.
And then I can keep
going after that.
So for the 2D voronoi honeycomb,
we have the random seed points.
And we used the
perpendicular bisectors.
And we used a minimum separation
distance between the points.
So we generated the structure.
And then we did a
finite element analysis.
And from that, we
calculated the modulus.
And what we found was
the finite element
analysis results were pretty
close to our closed form
analytical model.
And if we think
about the modulus,
the modulus is the
average stiffness
over the whole honeycomb.
And when we look at
the strengths next,
the strength is
going to be related
to the weakest few struts.
And we're going to find
that the strength doesn't
work quite the same way.
So first, we got the modulus.
That's sort of the simplest
thing to calculate.
And then after that,
we wanted to calculate
the compressive strength.
So we did a similar thing.
We set up the voronoi honeycomb
in the finite element analysis.
We had a few more elements
along the length of each strut.
And then we modeled
the elastic buckling
and the plastic
failure behavior.
And we looked at honeycombs
that had different densities.
And the lowest densities
failed by buckling.
And the higher densities failed
by a sort of plastic yielding.
And we assumed that the cell
walls were elastic, perfectly
plastic.
Remember we said if we have
a material where-- this
is for the solids-- so say
this is the stress in the solid
and that's the
strain in the solid.
If it behaves like that, we
say that's elastic, perfectly
plastic.
So we modeled the walls as
elastic, perfectly plastic.
And we made the ratio
of the solid modulus
to the yield strength
similar to what it would be
for bone, which is about 0.01.
And for that particular
value, the transition
between the elastic buckling
and the plastic yielding failure
was at a relative
density of about 0.035.
So then what we did was
we analyzed structures
that were a little lower
than that were equal to that
and then a little
higher than that.
So we would try and
see what happened
with these different
failure modes.
And then we found that if we
look at the compressive stress
strain curve, this model here
had a relative density of 15%.
And the transition occurred at
a relative density about 3.5%.
So this one here failed
by a plastic failure.
You can see, if we
unload it, there's
some plastic deformation.
We get a little
strange softening here,
which is kind of characteristic
of the plastic failure.
When we look at the overall
deformation of the honeycomb,
we saw local kind
of failure, like we
do in aluminum honeycombs.
So that was the kind
of stress strain
curve for a relatively
dense honeycomb that
failed by yielding.
And then this is one for
a much lower density.
This is now point 1.5%.
And this one fails
by elastic buckling.
And if we load it
up and unload it,
we recover most of
the deformation.
Barry, do you think you
could make that stop?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: There's a
chance it could be--
LORNA GIBSON: Below.
Just because we're recording it.
It just doesn't seem very good.
OK, so what we did was we
made five different voronoi
honeycomb.
So we had five sets
of seed points.
And we had five slightly
different geometries.
And then we averaged
the results of those.
So if we make that
calculation, this
is the strength of the
voronoi honeycomb here divided
by the strength of the periodic
regular hexagonal honeycomb.
And this was plotted
against relative density.
And you can see the strengths
for the voronoi structure are
a little bit lower than for
the regular periodic hexagonal
honeycomb.
And they reach a minimum here.
And the minimum's around
about 0.05 relative density.
So this was the 1.5.
That was a 3.5.
That's 5% and 15%.
AUDIENCE: Why is there like
a wide gap between 0.05 and--
LORNA GIBSON: Well,
I think because we
felt-- I think this one failed
by some combination of-- there
was a limit to how many of
these we were going to do.
And this is what we chose to do.
We wanted one that
we knew was going
to fail by plastic yielding.
And that was this one.
And we wanted one that
we knew it was going
to fail by elastic buckling.
And we wanted a
couple in between.
So we didn't do--
I guess we were
lazy is the real reason there's
not another point in the middle
there.
AUDIENCE: It just seems like
there might be a variable--
LORNA GIBSON: You think it might
go [CAREENING NOISE] like that.
Except there's a physical
reason why this happens.
And I'm going to get
to that in a minute.
So let me I'll finish
explaining this,
and then I'll put the
notes on the board.
So first of all,
the strength is less
than the regular
hexagonal honeycomb.
And then there's also
this minimum here
around about 5% density.
And I think the reason that
the strength is not the same
as in the voronoi in
the periodic honeycomb
is because if you look at
the distribution of strains--
or you can think of the
distribution of stresses--
so these were the normal strains
at the nodes in the honeycombs.
And the distribution here is
for the voronoi honeycomb.
So the voronoi
honeycomb, you have
lots of members of
different lengths.
There are different
orientations.
And so there's some distribution
of stresses and strains
in each member.
And that gives you
the distribution.
In the regular
hexagonal honeycomb,
if you look at just
the nodes, there's
really just the vertical member,
which has a certain strain.
And all the vertical
members are going
to have the same
strain at the nodes.
And then the obliques members,
if you just look at the nodes,
there's just going to
be a maximum tension
and a maximum
compression at the nodes.
Because there's a unit
cell and it repeats,
all the oblique ones are
going to have the same maximum
and the same minimum.
So the dashed lines here are
for the regular hexagonal
honeycomb.
So the thing to observe
here is that the voronoi has
some strains and
correspondingly some
stresses that are
outside the range
of the regular
periodic honeycomb.
And so if there's parts of it
that are seeing higher strains
and higher stresses, it's
going to fail at a lower load.
So I think it's
this distribution
because you've got
this random structure,
and you've got different lengths
and different orientations
of the members.
So that's one reason why
these strengths are less
than the periodic structure.
I think there's a
minimum here, because-- I
think before the
test I mentioned
there's some interaction between
elastic buckling and plastic
yielding.
And when you get
that interaction,
that also reduces the strength.
And so there's a
minimum near where
the crossover is between
the elastic buckling
and the plastic yielding.
So let me write some notes
of the compressive strength.
So we'll say the cell wall--
so the cell wall elastic,
perfectly plastic.
And the yield strength relative
to the modulus for the solid
was 0.1, which is pretty
much what it is for bone.
And we assumed that the possum's
ratio of the solid was 0.3.
And for this value
of sigma Ys over Es,
the transition between elastic
buckling and plastic yielding
is at about 3.5%
relative density.
So then we made
models with densities
that were a little bit less
than that and a little bit more
than that.
And then the strengths
we got from the voronoi
were between about
0.6 and 0.8 times
what we got from the periodic.
So then what we looked at
were these maximum strains
of the nodes.
And we found that because
the voronoi honeycomb
had a much broader distribution
of those strains, that
led to the lower strengths.
And then we found
the minimum strength
was at a density of about 5%.
And if you think just
about a pin ended column,
and you make a plot
of the strength--
so I'm just going
to say the strength
of that columm-- against
l/r, the slenderness ratio.
So say it's a cylinder,
l would be the length.
r would be the radius.
If you just had
Euler buckling, you
get a curve that
looked like that.
The Euler buckling load is pi
squared EI over l. squared.
So I goes as r to the 4th.
And if we get the
stress, then it's
going to be that divided
by the area of the column.
So it's pi squared
E. Moment of inertia
is pi r to the 4th
over 4 l squared.
And the area is pi r squared.
So it goes is as r over l
squared, or 1 over l over r
squared.
So this would be
the Euler buckling.
So that's elastic buckling.
But at some point, the
column is going to yield.
If I make it really,
really short, then it's
going to yield
before it buckles.
And at some point, this would
be the real stress here.
And this would be failure
by the plastic yielding.
And in practice, there's not
like a sharp corner here.
You know, if you made columns
of progressively longer length,
and you tested them, the
little short ones would yield.
So they'd be along here.
But they don't kind of yield
and the next one buckles.
In fact, you get
something like that.
So that when you're near
that transition, when you're
near this point here,
the actual failure stress
is a little bit less than that.
And I think that's partly
what's going on over there.
It's the minimum.
OK, so those two
studies, we just
looked at the modeling and
the strength of honeycombs.
And we were kind of looking at
how does the random structure
change the properties.
So the randomness
of the structure
didn't really change
the modulus much at all.
But it did affect the strength.
And then the next
thing we did was
we looked at putting
defects into the bone.
So we knew that the
bone, partly the density
is reduced by
thinning of the struts
and partly by resorption
when there's a lot of density
loss, a lot of bone loss.
So we wanted to look at putting
defects where we actually
removed some of the struts.
So we did another series
of voronoi models.
So we did another
series of tests
where we looked at it if we have
a certain density that we start
with and then we look at
losing the same bone mass
or relative density
in our honeycomb,
and we look at what happens if
we thin the struts versus if we
remove struts.
So these plots here show that.
And Matt Silva also did this.
So this is the residual modulus
plotted against the reduction
in relative density.
So residual modulus
is the modulus
after we've reduced the
density by some amount
relative to the initial modulus.
And if we have an intact
honeycomb where we just
thin the struts, we don't
remove any of the struts,
if we have an intact honeycomb,
as you reduce the density,
the modulus just
goes down like that.
So that's really just the same
as those analytical formulas
that we had.
But if you start
removing struts,
not too surprisingly,
the modulus
goes down substantially more.
And at this value here, I
think it was 30% or 35% density
reduction, you reach what's
called the percolation
threshold.
At the percolation
threshold, you
have two separate
pieces of material.
So obviously the
mechanical properties
are going to go down to zero
when you reach that percolation
threshold.
And then this plot over here
is the same sort of thing,
but now for strength.
So it's the strength
of the bone,
or the strength
of the honeycomb,
after you've either
thinned or resorbed
the wall, divided
by the strength
of the intact honeycomb.
And again, you're
reducing the density here.
And this is for the intact
model where you're just
thinning the struts.
And this is for the models where
you're removing the struts.
So you can see that
if you think of-- this
is kind of a simple model,
but if you think of the bone,
if you first thin
the struts, you're
going to lose a little
bit of strength.
But then if you start
removing the struts,
you're going to lose
a lot of strength.
So that's really where
people run into-- there's
much higher risk of fracture
once you get to the point
where you might be
resorbing struts.
OK, so let me see,
what's next thing?
OK, let me just
finish the slides,
and then I'll put the notes up.
So this is the
same sort of thing,
just plotting the strength and
the modulus on the same plot.
So you can see the shape of
the curves is very similar.
The modulus is a little bit more
sensitive than the strength.
And here we are
thinning, and here we
are removing the struts.
And then the next step was
that we made a model that
was more similar to bones.
So let me write down
the notes for this.
And then we'll do that one
that's more similar to bone.
Thought it didn't makes sense.
OK, so then we were
interested in trying
to model something that
was a little closer
to the structure of bone.
And so we set up
this model here.
So we started with
just a square voronoi.
So you just force the points
into a square, voronoi,
or a square pattern, you
get a square voronoi.
And then what we did
is we just perturbed
the points a little bit.
And we got this
perturbed voronoi array.
And so we made this model here.
And we took a piece
of vertebral bone.
And we measured the
angle of orientation
of a lot of the struts.
And we matched our voronoi
model to that distribution
in the bone.
So our model looked
something like this.
So you can kind of
see how it's more
or less vertical and
horizontal, but not exactly.
And here's a sort of comparison
with a slice of vertebral bone.
And again, because the
loads are more or less
vertical in the
bone, the trabeculae
tend to orient that way.
And then have some
horizontal struts.
So here you can see
on the left, we've
got a voronoi model that's
more or less representative
of the bone.
And we've removed
some of the struts.
So we're going to the same
thing with this model.
We thin the struts.
And we remove the struts.
And we try to see what
the residual strength is.
And you can see there's for
of at least a 2d model this
isn't a bad representation of
the vertebral trabecular bone.
And this was the
stress strain curve
for both the specimen of
the vertebral bone that
was tested and then the
honeycomb model that we
made to kind of match it.
So a similar kind of behavior.
This is how our model failed,
this sort of a local band
of struts that fail.
Let's call it local
deformation band.
And then what we
did was we thought
about changing the density.
And what we did was we
removed either horizontal
or vertical struts, or we
thinned either the vertical
or the horizontal struts.
So these are the same kinds
of plots as I showed before.
This is the residual modulus.
This is the residual strength.
This is the density reduction.
And here we're
reducing the density
by making struts thinner.
So it's still intact.
We haven't removed any struts.
But each of the
struts gets thinner.
And this top line is for
thinning the longitudinal
or the vertical struts.
And this was for thinning
the transverse or horizontal
struts.
And then this is for
removing struts here.
So we're removing
a bigger number.
So the more we remove, the
more the density changes.
And then this plot here
is for the strength.
So again, this is thinning.
So we're moving
either the horizontal
or the vertical
ones-- I'm sorry,
thinning either the horizontal
ones or the vertical ones.
And then this is
for removing struts.
And again removing more to
reduce the density more.
So you can kind
of see we're kind
of working our way to
more complex models here.
So this one here was
looking at the bone.
Let me write some
notes for this.
And then we did a
3D voronoi model.
So I'll do that one next.
Oop, over here.
So I'll just say the
model was adapted
to reflect the trabecular bones
study in the vertebrae more.
So we perturb a square
with array of seed points
to get a structure that
was more like the bone.
And then we looked at the
reduction in the thickness
and the number of strides in
the longitudinal and transverse
directions.
OK, and then the next model
we did was the 3D version.
So we made a same kind of thing.
But with the 3D model, we had
fewer cells in that model,
because once it
goes to 3D, you've
got more struts in each cell.
But this was the same idea.
We uniformly thinned the struts,
or we removed the struts.
And again, you can see
removing the struts is
a much bigger effect.
And also the other
thing to look at here
is for 3D the percolation
threshold is 50%.
So it kind of makes
sense that if it's in 3D,
and you've got struts
in all directions,
you're going to have
to remove more of them.
You're going to reduce
the density more
to break it into two separate
pieces at the percolation
threshold.
So that was the 3D model there.
And then this is just
a comparison of the 3D
with the 2D for the modulus.
We just did the modulus
for the 3D structure
because it sort of gets
computationally more involved.
So the 3D, these two
lines here corresponded
to removing the struts and
the change in the modulus.
And the little triangles were
the 3D voronoi calculation
that we did.
The little crosses here were
the same sort of calculation
done for tetratridecahedron.
One of my former
students had loaded that.
And then at the bottom
here are the lines
for the 2D structures, for
either a regular hexagonal cell
or for a 2D voronoi cell.
And you can see, there's
not a huge difference
whether or not you take
a regular structure
or a voronoi random structure.
But there's a fairly
significant difference
between the 2D and the 3D.
So the 3D, just you have
to remove more material
before you get the same
reduction in modulus.
So let me write
some notes for that.
So it's the same
kind of analysis,
but just with a 3D model.
So do you see the idea
with these models?
It was an attempt
to look at a way
that you could computationally
estimate how much modulus loss
or strength loss you get by
either thinning the struts
or removing the struts.
So I gave you a way to
model the osteoperotic bone.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you clarify
the percolation threshold?
LORNA GIBSON: So the
percolation threshold
is say you have some network
and you start removing things.
If your remove enough, you have
two separate pieces of things.
If you remove enough struts,
you have two separate pieces.
That's called the
percolation threshold.
So I think it's-- you want
to know why it's called that?
So I think that originated
because it wasn't
used in this kind of context.
I think instead it
was used in a context
where imagine you have 2D plate.
So you put 2D holes in
it, little circular holes.
And they we're looking at flow
of a fluid through the plate.
So you can imagine, if
you put enough holes,
eventually they line
up or they-- line up
is not the right term--
but there's enough of them
that they connect.
And you end up
with two separate.
You have a path
through for the fluid.
That's called the
percolation threshold.
But in mechanics it's sort
of two separate pieces.
OK, does that makes sense?
So you know, at the
percolation threshold,
the stiffness is zero because
you have two separate things
and the strength is 0.
AUDIENCE: So the two doesn't
have to be like separated by--
LORNA GIBSON: It
could be-- yeah, yeah,
it doesn't have to
be a straight line.
AUDIENCE: Does it
make a threshold
between whether everything
is interconnected?
LORNA GIBSON: Yes.
Or there's some path
that separates them.
Yeah, that's what it is.
OK, so that's the end of
the bit on osteoporosis.
I had a couple more things I
wanted to talk about on bone.
So the next part is on the idea
of using metal foams as a bone
substitute materials.
So when they make hip implants--
so they're typically metals.
They're titanium or
stainless steel or something.
Often what they do is they
coat the outside with some sort
of porous coating.
And the idea is
the porous coating
allows the bone to grow in.
So you can kind of imagine,
like especially on the stem
and around the head of a
femur, you'd like the bone
to grow into that to attach.
And having a porous
coating helps.
And there's a couple of
ways they do it currently.
They use porous sintered beads.
So they put little beads
of metal on the outside.
And the idea is that the bone
grows into the little gaps
between the beads.
Or sometimes if they
have-- not so much for hip
implants but sometimes when
people have say car accidents
and their face get
sort of smashed up,
and they have to have, say,
a plate put in their face,
and they need like
a flatter plate,
they use like a wire mesh.
And they have sort of a wire
mesh that goes on the outside.
And it's the same thing.
It's the idea to try to get the
bone to grow into that plate.
So some people are
thinking instead
of using the porous
sintered beads,
or instead of using one
of these wire mesh plates,
that you could use metal foams.
And so there's
been some interest
in using metal foams in
coatings of implants.
And longer term, there's
been some interest
in trying to make sort
of a vertebral body that
would involve using a metal
foam from the vertebral body.
So you know that whale
bone that we just
passed around, that vetebral
body, that cylindrical part,
it's almost all trabecular bone.
So there's some
interest in trying
to use metal foams
for spinal surgeries.
Maybe not to replace
the whole body.
But to use in part
of the surgery.
So I have a little
slide here which
shows a bunch of metal
foams that people
have made with the idea in
mind that perhaps some of this
could be used in
orthopedic surgery.
So these are some different
kinds of metal foams.
And these ones are made
from titanium or tantalum.
So typically, the metals that
they use in orthopedic implants
are the cobalt chromium alloys.
Titanium, they sometimes use
tantalum or stainless steel.
And they use those because
they're biocompatible.
And they're very
corrosion resistant.
So these ones here
are mostly titanium.
And this is one
that's a tantalum.
So let me just go over
how they make them.
And then I've got another
slide that goes over it
in more detail.
And I'll write a few notes down.
So this guy on the
top left up here,
that's made by taking an
open cell polyurethane foam,
like a seating foam,
like a cushion.
And then what they do
is they heat that up
in an inert atmosphere,
so that they
are left just with the carbon.
So it's a sort of
vitreous carbon.
And then what they do
is they coat that carbon
by a CVD process with tantalum.
And so they end up
with a tantalum foam
with a very thin layer
of carbon at the core.
The carbon makes up
something like 1%
of the final composition
and the tantalum is the 99%.
So that's sort of a
replica process there.
This one here is made by
another replica process.
They take an open cell
polyurethane foam.
They infiltrate
it with a slurry,
which has the titanium
hydride particles in it.
Remember when we talk about
processing of the foams
at the beginning, I said, if you
heat up the titanium hydride,
eventually the hydrogen
would be driven off,
and you'd be left
with the titanium.
So they do that, and
then they sinter it,
and they get a titanium foam.
This one is made by a
fugitive phase process.
So the idea with
a fugitive phase
is you burn off some phase.
So you could mix powders,
consolidate the powders,
then you burn off
one of the powders.
And you're left
with the other one.
And then you need to
sinter that together
to make it have some reasonable
mechanical properties.
This one here is made by
using a foaming agent.
This one's made by
expansion of argon gas.
I think when we talked
about the metal foams,
we talked about the
idea of packing, say,
titanium powder in a can.
And then you evaporate the can.
And you then pressurize
the can with argon gas.
And then you heat treat it.
So you heat it up.
And as you heat it up,
the argon gas expands.
And you're left with the pores.
This one's made by a
freeze casting process.
I have a slide.
And I'll talk about
that in a minute.
This one's made by a
selective laser sensory.
So it's like a 3D printing.
But instead of printing
in ink, this time
you have a bed of a powder.
And you've got a laser
that selectively sinters.
So you turn the
laser on and off.
And where it's on, it's
going to bind the material.
When it's off, it's not
And then you raise the thing.
You make a little
bit more powder.
You do it all over again.
And you can get
different patterns.
And then this is made
by a sort of process
in which they take powders and
press them and ignite them.
But I think that's not
very commonly used.
So this is some more details
about how they might do it.
So this is the fugitive
phase process here.
You could take a titanium
and a filler powder,
pack them together.
You know, you'd mix them
up, pack them together.
You would raise it to
a certain temperature
to decompose the filler.
So typically the
filler decomposes
at a lower temperature than
what you sinter the powder,
the metal powder that's left.
So you decompose the filler.
You drive that off.
And then you sinter
the metal powder.
And you're left with
porous titanium.
This one's the expansion
of the foaming agent.
So you take your
titanium powder.
You might have a binder
and then a foaming agent.
Mix those all together.
They heat them up until
typically the binder
becomes a liquid.
And the foam foams
up the liquid binder.
Then they drive off the binder.
And then they sinter at a
higher temperature the titanium.
So you you've got a
porous titanium left.
This is the freeze casting
or the freeze drying process.
So here they would take titanium
powder and put it in agar.
And the agar's in water.
So the agar is like
a jelly, like a gel.
But it's mostly water.
And then if you freeze it, what
happens is the water freezes.
And it drives off
the titanium agar
into the interstitial zones
between the frozen ice
crystals.
So these little dots here
are the ice crystals.
The ice crystals are
growing as it gets colder.
And as the ice crystals
get bigger and bigger,
you're left with the
titanium and the agar
in between those ice crystals.
And then if you
sublimate the ice off,
you're left with a porous thing.
And you can sinter the
titanium if you want
to make it a little more dense.
And this is a rapid
prototyping thing here.
So you spread the powder.
You could either
print a binder or you
could use a laser to sort
of almost weld the particles
together.
Then you would drop the
piston, put more powder down,
have the binder go again
until you made your product.
And then you would get rid
of all the unbound material.
And you'd have
your final product.
OK, so these are
some of the methods
they can use for
making metal foams.
I don't know, should
I write notes?
Or are you good if I just
put the notes on the website?
I'll put the notes
on the website.
And then this is a stress strain
curve for a titanium foam.
So it looks like all
these other kinds of foams
and bone and wood and everything
else that we've looked at.
And this is some data
for titanium foams
that are made by
different processes.
And we've just taken different
data from the literature
and put it together.
So this is the modulus here.
This is a slope of 2.
You can see some of the data
is sort of near that slope,
but below it.
And there is obviously a
large spread in the data too.
But if you go back and
look at the different types
of structures,
then not all these
have this kind of typical
foam-like structures.
The structures aren't all
quite like a foam either.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So is there
any objective in this
to make the foam similar in
structure to the bone that
will be growing into it?
Or does it just need
to be scaffolding?
LORNA GIBSON: I think
for this, they just
want to make a porous thing.
And they're thinking
about coatings.
So the coatings
aren't necessarily
similar to the bone.
When we finish the
section on bone,
we're going to start
talking, I think,
about tissue engineering.
And when we talk about
tissue engineering,
people have made
scaffolds to try
to make them the same shape
as the anatomical part
that they're trying to mimic.
And then they make a
cellular kind of core.
So they have made some more
of an attempt to do that.
I could give you
a sneak preview.
Would you like a preview?
So these are some scaffolds
that are generated from a making
different kinds of tissue.
These aren't all from bone.
But this one here, for example,
is for regenerating bone.
And they've printed it
in this exact geometry,
because that's going to
replace some anatomical piece.
And they want it
in that geometry.
So I'll talk more about that.
But so for the scaffolds,
they sometimes do that.
But not so much for
these bone coatings.
Let's see.
Se we did that.
We did that.
So these are the data.
And then over here, there's
the compressive strength.
And again, you know, this is
our line with a slope of 3/2.
Again, there's a lot of
scatter, because there's
a lot of variation in the
structure of these things.
But it's in the ballpark.
So are we good with metal foams?
And there's just like a page
and a half of little notes.
Should I just put
that on the website?
You're good?
OK.
OK, so the last topic I
wanted to talk about on bone
has to do with how people
look at the structure of bone
in evolution and in
evolutionary studies.
So the idea here
is, in particular
in looking at sort of
pre-human species, sort
of hominid species, people
are interested in when
primates went from being
quadruplets to bipeds.
So obviously, bipedalism,
walking on two legs,
is characteristic of us.
And people would
like to know if they
find some fossil-- you can't
just tell from the fossil
directly is it a
biped or a quadraped.
You can't see the
species moving because it
doesn't exist anymore.
So you'd like to have some
way of making some estimate of
whether or not it was
a biped or a quadruped.
Let me get my notes
together here.
So I wanted to kind of look at
the big picture a little bit
and look at the evolution
of different species.
And this is a phylogenetic
sort of chart.
And this is kind of-- have
you heard of the tree of life?
This is like the tree of life.
So this piece of it is--
metazoa is for animals.
So not plants, animals.
And this goes back
about 1.2 billion years.
So these are millions
of years ago.
And then these are different
sort of eras and ages
that are defined.
And when we have a branch here,
this is a common ancestor.
And then this is a
branch in one direction,
and that's a branch
in another direction.
So these points
here, like 1 and 2
and so on, the
implication there is
that there was a common
ancestor to everything
that traces back to there.
So this point here, 1,
is 1.2 billion years ago.
So this was sort of very
early kind of species.
And the very first things were,
well, multicellular things.
I mean, there were little
amoeba type things.
But the more sort of
sophisticated animals
were sponges.
And there's three kind of
classes of the sponges.
There's calcarea.
And they're called calcarea
because they're mineralized.
And they're mineralized
with a calcium carbonate.
And then there's
another branch of them
called-- I don't know if
I'm going to say this right,
but hexactinellida.
And those have glass.
Those are called glass
sponges because they have
SiO2 is the mineral in those.
And then there's these
guys here the demospongiae.
I think some of those have
calcium carbonate and some
of them don't.
Oh, no, some of
them have silica.
And some of them don't.
So these things here are sort
of very early multicellular
structures.
And the mineral in
them is either calcium
carbonate or silica.
And then if we move
up, I've sort of
highlighted a few of them.
The cnideria-- I
know there's a C,
but that's actually--
when I say s-nideria,
my biologist
friends laugh at me.
And they say no, no,
no, it's nideria.
The cnideria are the
corals and the jellyfish.
And corals are also mineralized
with calcium carbonate.
And you can see they
branched off something
like a billion years ago.
Then we get up here.
These are the mollusks.
So the mollusks are
things like bivalves,
like if you like to eat
claims, things like that.
So bivalves, snails, and
things like octopi, octopus.
So those are all molluscs.
And molluscs, when
they're mineralized,
also are calcium carbonate.
So those are the calcium
carbonate kind of shell.
So we haven't got up
to anything bony yet.
Bone is collagen plus
a calcium phosphate.
So we haven't gotten to anything
that's a calcium phosphate yet.
Then another large
class is arthropoda.
That's insects and
spiders and crustaceans.
Those all have a
chiton skeleton.
So if you think of like the
exoskeleton of an insect
or a spider, those are chiton.
And crustaceans, things
like lobsters, those
also have a chiton shell.
And in crustaceans, it
might be mineralized.
But again, the mineral
is a calcium carbonate.
So all the way up here,
most of these things,
if there is any mineral,
it's calcium carbonate.
And if we get up finally
to the vertebraes,
the vertebraes have the calcium
phosphate and have a bone,
like what we think
of as real bone.
So the vertebrates
obviously involve things
like mammals, birds,
snakes, and fish.
So this is kind of the
big picture going back.
And sort of one of
the interesting things
is that bone doesn't
come along until you
get somewhere over here.
And I have one more
little, nice slide here.
So when I talked
about the sponges,
they were these guys here
with the glass sponges.
Joanna Aizenberg at Harvard did
a nice study on glass sponges.
And she looked at this one here.
It's called the
Venus flower basket
is kind of the common name.
And it has this
hierarchical structure.
And it's remarkably
stiff and tough.
And what she did
in her paper was
look at optical and
mechanical properties.
But they looked at the structure
at different length scales.
So there's kind of a cellular
structure at this length scale.
It's kind of a tube.
This was just a picture I took
in a natural history museum.
But if you look at
higher magnification,
each little strut is
made up of sort of fibers
and has a hierarchical
structure itself.
So that's just one
of the sponges.
And here's a similar
chart for the vertebrates.
So this point here is where
the other chart kind of
branched off.
And if we start with the
earliest things again,
the earliest ones with
the most common ancestor
back here is something
called cyclostomata.
And those are things
like jawless fish,
so things like
lamprey and hagfish.
Do you know what a hagfish is?
It's this kind of eely thing.
And I have the
video for you if you
don't know what a hagfish is.
So let me get out of
here because it's just
an amazing thing, the hagfish.
OK, so let's see,
I got my sound on.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
REPORTER: Here, at the
University of Guelph,
about an hour outside
Toronto, materials scientist
Atsuko Negishi and
biologist Julia Herr
think that these lovely
creatures, called hagfish,
may revolutionize how we
make strong materials.
ATSUKO NEGISHI: These
are specific hagfish.
They're well known for their
unique defense mechanism.
REPORTER: So if I wanted to
see this, what would we do?
Like could we poke
at it with a stick?
JULIA HERR: I think the best way
to do it is to reach in there
and grab one.
REPORTER: Oh, my gosh,
look at that disgusting--
oh, no, I've been slimed.
I feel like an outtake
from Ghostbusters.
Look at the quantities
of this stuff.
[END PLAYBACK]
LORNA GIBSON: He used to do
this for The New York Times.
And I think he's got
his own going on,
but he used to make
these little videos.
And he had a show on PBS a year
or two ago all about materials.
And there were like
four different episodes.
And he talked about
different kinds of materials.
And he went to different labs.
But he's quite a character.
But anyway the hagfish
have this defense mechanism
where they make the slime.
And I don't know if you
know Professor McKinley over
in mechanical
engineering here at MIT,
but he collaborates with
those people of Guelph.
And he studies what he
calls non-Newtonian fluids.
Well, a lot of people
call non-Newtonian fluids.
A Newtonian fluid is
a thing like water,
where the viscosity is a
constant no matter what sort
of strain rate you shear it at.
And a non-Newtonian fluid
does not have that property.
The viscosity changes.
And some of them have a
strength, like in the hagfish
one has a strength.
So Gareth's studies things like
this kind of hagfish slime.
I don't know if
he still has them.
He used to have hagfish
in his lab over him
building, whatever it is, 1
or 3 or something over there.
OK, so that's what
the hagfish are,
just because that's amusing.
And they don't have bone.
So they and the jawless
fish don't have bone,
even though they're
called vertebrates.
Then the next sort
of most recent thing
is the chondrocytes.
Those are the cartilaginous
fish, so things like shark.
So sharks don't
actually have bones.
They have cartilage.
And they have a little
bit of mineralization
in the cartilage, but they
don't actually have bone.
And the first thing
that actually has a bone
is the ray finned fish,
which are these guys here.
And that occurred about
450 million years ago.
And then everything in the
vertebrate since then is bony.
So there's coelacanth-- I don't
know if you've ever see those.
Every now and then they find
one of these things in Florida
or something-- lung fish.
There's these guys here, which
are the frogs and the toads
and the salamanders.
So it's finally
getting to be spring
after the winter from hell.
And the salamanders
are going to come out
into the vernal pools and mate.
And it's cute.
So anyway, they come
out this time of year.
And then there's
the amniota, things
that have eggs of
one sort or another.
So that includes us, the
mammals, the birds, the snakes,
and the turtles.
And so those would have
branched off about there.
So the last thing I
wanted to point out here
is that there's this
huge kind of diversity
of animals that have
evolved over millions
and millions of years.
And that the first ones
that were mineralized
used the calcium carbonate and
that the bony type materials
didn't really evolve or
didn't appear until about 450
million years ago.
And then these are
the vertebrates that
have these kind of bony things.
So as I've said many
times now, the bone
grows in response to loads.
And the bone structure
reflects the mechanical loads
and the function.
And evolutionary studies have
looked at both cortical bone
and trabecular bone
architecture to try
to say something about the
locomotion of the animal
or of the species.
So there's ones that
look at cortical bone.
But I'm just going to talk about
one that deals with trabecular
bone.
So this study was done
by a group of peoples,
the first author was Rook.
And what they studied
was the ileum.
So this is a pelvis.
And there's the ileum is one
of the bones in the pelvis.
And they found fossils
of a hominid species that
was about 8 million years old,
called Oreopithecus bambolii.
And bambolii refers
to the place in Italy
where these fossils were found.
And so they found two--
or at least somebody
found two pieces of an ilium.
And they took x-rays.
And they made a
digital reconstruction
so that they would get
one ilium-- it turned out
that the two pieces were two
different parts-- so they could
make a whole one out
of the two pieces.
And then they looked at the
structure of the trabecular
bone.
And they compared that
structure to the structure
of the trabecular bone in
humans and other primates.
And they wanted to see is it
more like the humans, which
are obviously
biped, or is it more
like some of the primates,
which are quadrupeds.
So this just shows for a
human and a non-human primate
what the structure
of the ilium is.
And these little black
boxes with the letters
are what are called
anatomical landmarks.
So they're sort of
comparable spots on the bone
of different species.
And what they were
doing was looking
at the trabecular architecture
at these different spots.
So you can kind
of see how they're
more or less analogous in
the two different species.
And this is the digitally
reconstructed ilium
that they put together
from their fossil species.
And again, these
little letters refer
to these anatomical landmarks.
And then what they
did was they compared
the Oreopithicus, the fossil,
with the human and then three
non-human primates.
So these four images
are all from the fossil.
These are the human.
These are champi,
siamang and baboon.
And this square here
corresponds to that one there.
This is B, corresponds
to that one.
And C and D are those two there.
So they had two
fossils, they made
the digital reconstruction.
They looked at certain areas.
And then they looked at
the same or analogous areas
in these other species.
And they tried to look for
similarities and differences
in the bone structure.
So let's look at this first
box A. You can see there's
a very white bit here.
And the white corresponds
to more dense.
So there's a white bit that's
more dense in their fossil.
And in the human bone, you
see is a similar sort of band
right there.
And if you look at the
other non-human primates,
that band is missing.
So that says to them,
OK, this feature,
this one feature at least, is
more similar to the-- sorry,
in the fossil here is
more similar to the human
than it is to the
non-human primates.
And then they had
three other landmarks
that they looked at like that.
So this one here again is
a sort of dense regions.
So you can see that
white dense region.
There's some there.
There's some here.
So those are the
fossil and the human.
But there's a teeny bit
here and a teeny bit there.
But it's not as pronounced
in the non-human primates.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: From I
get at least so far,
the portions of the bone that
are dense versus not dense
seem less relevant
to the direction
of loading than the
orientation of the foamy parts
of the trabecular bone.
LORNA GIBSON: So the density
reflects more or less
the magnitude of the stresses.
So if the stresses are higher,
it's going to be denser.
And the orientation of the
bone, like whether or not
which way the
struts are oriented,
that reflects the sort of ratio
of the principal stresses.
So if the principal stresses
go in a certain direction,
the bone's going to tend to
line up in that direction.
That's what that Guinea fowl
study was kind of about.
OK?
Are we good?
OK.
And then these
other two, so in B--
and you can't really
see it from here,
but they looked at the sort of
architecture of the trabecular
bone.
And they said that it was
more similar in the fossil
in the human than it was in
these other three primates.
And this region here, this looks
very similar to that bit there
to me.
But I think there was some
other feature about this region
that they were looking at.
And again, it was more
similar to the human
than it was to the
non-human primates.
So by just looking at
the pattern of the bone
and the density of the
bone and comparing it
to these other species, they
said that the-- and you know
the hip, because we're
standing like this,
you would kind of expect to
see differences in the hip.
That's why they wanted
to look at the ilium.
So the conclusion they made
was that these observations
suggested that the
species was bipedal,
or at least spent some of
its time as a bipedal animal.
And I think that might be it.
Do I have more I have
one little summary here.
So just to summarize what
we've done on bone this week.
We talked about the
structure of the bone.
We talked about mechanical
properties in the foam models.
We talked about osteoporosis
in the voronoi models,
how you can try to
represent the loss of bone
and the loss of bone
strength using those models.
We talked just a little
bit about the idea
of using metal foams
as bone substitutes
or coatings as
implants, and then
this little bit on
trabecular architecture
and evolutionary studies.
I have some notes,
but I think we've
got just a couple minutes left.
So maybe I'll just scan those
and put them on the website?
Are we good with that?
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about what we just looked
at about the different species.
We always consider on
the density changes.
Can there always be
changes in the solids?
LORNA GIBSON: So it
changes a little bit
from one species to another.
So the question is, does the
solid properties of the bone,
the solid bone itself change?
So if you look at cortical
bone in different species,
it changes a little bit, but
like 10%, not a huge amount.
So the two most common
things people have compared
are bovine bone and human bone.
And there is a slight
difference between them.
But it's not a huge difference.
One of the other things people
have looked at in osteoporosis
that I didn't really
talk about was
there's another
whole set of things
that can go on that reflect
what you're talking about.
So they talk about
bone quality as well.
And when they talk
about bone quality,
they're talking about are there
micro cracks in the solid.
So you might imagine
as you get older,
it's not just that
you lose the struts
or that the struts get
thinner, but the solid bit
itself has more cracks in it.
So you can imagine if
the solid bone itself had
little micro cracks, then
it too would be weaker.
And then you think
what I put up was bad.
It gets even worse if
you put that in as well.
So, yes, people do look
at bone quality, which
is sort of looking at with age.
And typically it's
fairly elderly people
that the bone
quality is an issue.
I guess there are certain
diseases where it's an issue.
But in osteoporosis, it's
sort of elderly people.
Any thing else?
Should I stop there for today?
So there were hardly
any equations in this.
Did you know that?
So we got to the part where
there's lots of equations.
So next week I'm going to
talk about tissue engineering.
I think I'm going
to talk a little bit
about different kinds of
scaffolds, how they make
scaffolds, how the
scaffolds fit sort
of into an anatomical
things, what is that supposed
to represent, how they use
them clinically a little bit.
And we had a research project
on osteochondrol scaffold,
so scaffolds for replacing
bone and cartilage.
And I'm going to
talk a little bit
about that as sort of a case
study in tissue engineering
scaffolds.
And I have some stuff
on cell mechanics
and how biological cells
interact with scaffold.
I don't if we're going
to get to that next week
or not, but somewhere
close to that.
So the next bit is on tissue
engineering scaffolds,
osteochondrol scaffolds,
cell mechanics.
And there's not that many
equations in that part either.
So OK.